The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
OK, good morning.
So I'd like to pick up from
where we left off last time.
So we were discussing
the various properties
of the Fourier
transform and what
they mean in terms of the
Fraunhofer diffraction
patterns.
So what we're doing last
time when we ran out of time
was we were proving the
convolution theorem.
So this is the proof here.
And just to remind
you very briefly,
we start with an expression
that looks like a convolution.
We have an output
function equals an input
function times a kernel.
Then what we did is we wrote
each one of those, the input
as well as the kernel, we wrote
those as Fourier transforms.
Here they are respectively.
Then we rearranged the integrals
and the order of integration.
And we noticed that this
expression here is also
known as a delta function.
The integral of an exponential,
of a complex exponential
from minus infinity to
infinity is a delta function.
Oh, too bright.
OK, I think that's
a little bit better.
I can rewrite this.
Let me do it one step at a time.
So I can rewrite now
this big integral.
Unfortunately, the black
marker has run out of steam,
so I'll switch color.
So since we have a double
integral with respect
to the two frequency variables
and a delta function inside,
the delta function will knock
out one of the integrals.
And we simply replace the--
well, let's pick--
we can pick whichever
variable we want to
integrate, so let's pick u1.
So we'll simply get du1 times
G sub in of u1 H of u1 one
e to the i 2 pi u1 x prime.
And now we realize and
remember what this is.
If you go back to the
beginning of the derivation,
this is the outcome
of the convolution.
So this is actually-- let
me write it out again.
This is G sub out of x prime.
What we've got now is
a Fourier transform.
Because, you see, here is
the Fourier transform kernel.
Actually-- I'm
sorry-- what we've got
is a Fourier integral.
We've got to write the
outcome of the convolution
as a Fourier
integral, where this
is the Fourier integral
kernel or the inverse Fourier
transform kernel.
The two terms mean
the same thing.
And this is the actual
inverse Fourier transform.
So, therefore, this result
is equivalent to G sub
out of u equals G sub
in of u times H of u.
So this is, then, the proof of
the convolution theorem, which
says that if two
functions are related
as a convolution
with a kernel, then
the equivalent relationship
in the Fourier domain
is actually a product of the
Fourier transform of the input
function times the Fourier
transform of the kernel.
So this mathematical-- this
analytical result is what
you've seen in the simulations
that I have on this screen
here, where the two--
I will do this in one dimension.
The simulations
are obviously 2D,
but it's a little bit easier
to do everything in 1D here
so we don't spend too
much time writing.
So the two functions that
we have here are actually--
one of them is a sinusoid.
So if I have a sinusoid--
I keep using the blue
marker, [INAUDIBLE]..
So the sinusoid is--
let me just write it
with full contrast
to save some writing here.
This is a sinusoid.
Then it's Fourier
transform will actually--
as we have said
several times, it
will consist of three
delta functions.
Then we have another function
which looks like a rectangle.
That's on the right-hand
side, top right.
And we've already seen this one.
So the rectangle is a
rectangular function.
If it has a width, let's say,
a, then the Fourier transform
will look like this.
And we call this
the sinc function.
So the height of this
function is a by virtue
of the scaling theorem.
And then the nulls, they go
like 1/a, 2/a, and so on.
And then, symmetrically,
on the negative side,
minus 1/a, minus 2/a,
and so on and so forth.
So these are two Fourier
transform relationships.
Now, what we see
on the bottom side
is basically a grating
which is truncated.
So I take my infinite grating.
It continues on and on.
And then I truncate it.
That is, I multiply--
I multiply it by a rectangular
function which sets the side--
which sets the aperture
of the truncation.
So the way I've written it,
the width of this boxcar
would be a, and the period
of the grating itself
would be uppercase lambda.
So, of course, we can
go ahead and compute
this Fourier transform
analytically,
but that would be quite painful.
We'd have to do a lot of
changes of variable and so on.
However, by virtue of
the convolution theorem,
because this is a product,
this Fourier transform
will be a convolution.
So, basically, what we
have to do in order--
when we multiply these two
results in this domain,
in this domain we
have to convolve them.
So what is now-- so
the assumption here
is that the size of the
boxcar is actually bigger
by the size of the period.
It does not have
to be much bigger,
but it's nice if it
is bigger for what I'm
about to draw to be correct.
So what we get if we can
convolve this pattern
with the three delta
functions, each delta
will produce a replica
of this function centered
at the location of
the delta function.
So, therefore, we'll
get three replicas
of this sinc pattern centered
at the corresponding locations.
So let me draw this a
little bit carefully here.
So I'll try to be as
accurate as I can.
OK.
So here are the two--
well, there's three
delta functions.
One is at the origin.
One is at minus 1 up on
lambda, and the other
is at plus 1 up on lambda.
And then, on each
one of those, I'm
going to center one
of the sinc functions.
So here is one sinc
function, and here
is another sinc function,
and another one.
So I tried to do it carefully.
Why is this taller?
Because, if you
recall, the delta
function that was at
the origin is actually
twice the size of the
other two delta functions.
So the size of this one
would be a/2 actually,
because, if you
recall, we're also
picking up one factor of
a from the sinc itself.
Then the size of this would
be a/4, and the size of this
would also be a/4.
When I say the size,
I mean the height.
And then where are
the nulls located?
Well, these nulls are simple.
They're still at 1/a, minus 1/a.
Where is this null?
For example, this null would
be at 1 over lambda plus 1/a.
And then I have another
null over here at 1
over lambda minus 1/a,
and so on and so forth.
And then I have more nulls
at 1 over lambda minus 2/a,
minus 3/a, and so
on and so forth.
And now my assumption
that I have
several periods of the
grating with the boxcar,
you can see it is quite
convenient because I can draw
these sinc functions and
I can kind of ignore what
happens in between over here.
As you can imagine,
something complicated
will happen over here because
the sincs are actually
adding coherently, so
something funky will happen.
But if they're
pretty far apart, you
can see that the envelope
of the sinc function
actually decays quite fast.
So I can more or less ignore
what is happening over here,
and I can simply draw
the sinc function.
Of course, this is because
I'm doing it by hand.
If I use a computational tool,
such as MATLAB or Mathematical,
it will do it for me.
So this is the
one-dimensional calculation,
that is easier to do by hand.
As a bonus, I think you
guys have already computed--
or, if you haven't
already, you will
compute some time
between Tuesday midnight
and Wednesday at 8:00 AM.
Some time you will compute
the same convolution
for the two-dimensional case.
And you can see the result here.
So, in effect, this
saves you from--
well, at least you know if your
result is correct or wrong.
If you derive something
that looks like this,
then you know you've
done correctly.
So you see what's happened.
If you had the infinite
grating, the infinite grating
gives you three
delta functions whose
axis is kind of perpendicular
to the fringes of the grating,
and the one that the
origin is stronger.
Of course, the
rectangular function
produces a sinc pattern.
And then when you
convolve them, when
you have a tilted grating now
and multiply it by a rect,
then you see that you get
three sinc patterns oriented
along the same axis, which is
perpendicular to the fringes
of the grating.
But the sinc pattern
itself is actually
perpendicular to the
rectangular aperture.
So this is what the
convolution theorem says.
And, of course, you
can turn it around.
You can actually turn
the grating around
and rotate the aperture.
In this case now, again, you
will see the sincs oriented
parallel to the fringes again,
but now the rectangular pattern
itself is rotated, and therefore
the sinc patterns themselves
are rotated.
So the reason we use these
properties is because--
again, as you can
imagine, if you
were to write this as
an explicit integral,
it can be done and
you would-- of course
you would still get
the correct result,
but it would be quite
painful to compute.
So now that we have
all these results,
we can actually apply them.
So far, these were
mathematically results.
I could pretend
I'm teaching 18085,
or whatever it is that
you learn those things.
But this is also-- of course,
they actually become Fraunhofer
diffraction patterns if you
simply perform a scale--
a coordinate change.
So the Fourier transforms,
we compute them with respect
to the frequency variables,
u and v we call them.
Goodman calls them
F sub x, F sub y,
but it is actually
the same variable.
Well, if you substitute
a special variable
and you multiply by the
scaling factor lambda z,
that we saw the derivation
in the previous lecture--
I'm not going to do it again--
then you actually get the
Fraunhofer diffraction pattern.
So it's a simple
scaling argument.
And you can tell that--
well, at least it is
plausibly correct.
Here, the units are
correct, because u and v
are frequency variables.
So, therefore, their
units are inverse meters.
And then multiply
it by meter squared.
The wavelength is meter,
the distance is meter.
So, therefore, I get meters.
So the units are correct.
And this is one
example that we did.
Then here's another
one where I shrink
the rectangular aperture.
And, of course, the Fraunhofer
diffraction pattern will grow.
We call this a similarity
or scaling theorem.
Then I can, for example,
use the shift theorem
to calculate the
Fraunhofer diffraction
pattern from three rectangles.
As we discussed
the last time, this
will give rise to a sinusoidal
modulation in the Fraunhofer
domain.
And you can also do
the convolution theorem
in this case with a
truncated aperture,
and so on and so forth.
So this basically concludes the
discussion of the Fraunhofer
diffraction pattern.
But since we've been
discussing Fourier transforms,
there's another very
basic property of Fourier
transforms that I would
like to introduce here,
and then we will see it in
full glory for the next two
lectures, and that
is spatial filtering.
So spatial filtering is
basically the following.
It says if you go
to this Fraunhofer
domain, or, in general,
in the transform domain--
which, we will see
a little bit later,
that we don't need to have
to go very far actually.
By using a lens, we can produce
a Fraunhofer diffraction
pattern at the back
focal plane of the lens.
That's very convenient.
But if I go here and I
do some modification,
and then take another Fourier
transform, then, of course,
the signal I reconstruct
is not identical
to my original
signal, but it will
have changed because I've
modified the frequency
spectrum.
So this is called
spatial filtering.
So here's an example
that I have constructed.
So in this case, I've
contacted the signal
in the space domain that
looks like three sinusoids.
Now, you cannot tell very
clearly from this pattern that
you have three sinusoids, but if
you take the Fourier transform,
then you see three
spots here, three dots.
Actually, you see six.
But you recall that each
sinusoid corresponds
to two dots.
So the conjugate dots here,
this one and this one,
they are one sinusoid.
This and this one,
another sinusoid.
This and this one are
yet another sinusoid.
So spatial filtering, a
very simple occurrence
of spatial filtering is what
happens if, for example, you
go in with some black
marker or some opaque screen
in the case of optics and
you remove one of these dots.
If you do that in the transform
domain, then you will see it.
Now, watch as I
transition the slide.
You will see that the
spatial pattern also changes.
OK.
So now it becomes
kind of horizontal,
and it is horizontal because
the two dominant-- the two
dominant sinusoids are actually
along the horizontal axis.
So, therefore,
your grooves are--
I'm sorry.
Your grooves are vertical
because the two dots here
are on the horizontal axis.
But there's also
a weaker sinusoid
that gives rise to
these weak diagonal
fringes that you see over here.
But, basically, you
can see that one
of the three spatial
frequencies has vanished here.
So this is the simplest
case of spatial filtering.
And, of course, you
can generalize it.
Here's again the Red Sox--
or I should say the GO SOX
pattern on the Boston high rise
that I showed last time.
And this is the spatial
frequency representation
or the Fourier transform
of this pattern.
And then we can apply
various filters.
For example, if I
go with a filter
and I block all the
high frequencies,
then you can see that my
pattern appears blurred.
In fact, it is
more than blurred.
The windows have kind of
disappeared of the building.
And that is because the
windows, if I go back,
you will see that the--
hi, Colin.
You're back.
COLIN: Yes.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Welcome.
COLIN: Sorry I'm late.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Oh, no problem.
I thought you were
still in Poland.
COLIN: No, I got back.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Oh.
Oh, OK, welcome back.
And so the windows,
if you recall,
the windows are kind of
periodic in this high rise here.
So they correspond to these
dots in the frequency domain,
kind of like delta functions.
And because, in this case,
I have blocked the dots,
you see that the windows
disappear from the high rise.
And, of course, you can do
other funky kind of filters.
This is called a
band pass filter.
And, in this case,
the windows reappear
because now I center this
doughnut, this annulus.
I centered it so that some of
these dots in the frequency
domain, they survive.
And you can see that,
of course, the--
well, it is not
fully reconstructed,
the original
building, of course,
because there's still
spatial frequencies missing.
But you can see that the pattern
of windows of the high rise
has kind of reappeared.
Now, what happened
to the sign GO SOX?
It vanished, and it vanished
because, in this case,
I have blocked the
lower frequencies.
The GO SOX sign, it has
survived the low pass filter
because this is a relatively
slow-varying signal, right?
So its frequency content, you
expect it to be centered--
I'm sorry-- to be concentrated
near the center of the Fourier
domain where the
frequencies are low.
When we do the band pass
filter, the GO SOX vanishes.
And that is because I blocked
the low frequencies where
this signal was represented.
So you can see that you can do
quite interesting manipulations
on images using this concept
of spatial frequency.
And, actually, the GO SOX
signal has not quite vanished.
If you look carefully, there is
a little bit of evidence of it
here, but it's
quite hard to see.
And, of course, there's
a little bit of evidence
because there is a little bit
of the frequency content leaking
into the intermediate
frequencies.
So, therefore, some
of it has survived,
but mostly it is gone.
So that is the--
so it is not a perfect filter,
but it works quite well.
Of course, the other thing
that vanished is the average.
You can see that
the sky, that used
to be kind of an average
gray, it is gone also.
Because the average--
of course, the average
is presented at the zero spatial
frequency, and I blocked it.
So, therefore, the
average is gone.
So this is called
a spatial filter.
OK.
So we're still one
lecture behind.
So this is what I was supposed
to have done last Wednesday.
And if you look ahead, there is
some discussion of the transfer
function of a
Fresnel propagation,
and then something
called the Talbot effect.
So I will not do this right now.
I will postpone it, if
I may, for next week.
What I would like
to do is I would
like to switch to the lecture
that I posted today online,
and that is Lecture 10A.
The reason I'm doing that--
I will go back and talk
about the Talbot effect.
Don't worry.
But the reason
I'm doing that now
is because I would
like to press on
with the concept of
spatial frequencies
and spatial filtering.
Because it is quite an important
one, and I think the sooner
you learn it, the better.
Talbot effect, well
you can learn later.
But this business of spatial
filtering, in my experience,
it takes quite a bit
of time to digest,
so I would like to do it
sooner rather than later.
So I already alluded to that.
I said that this Fraunhofer
diffraction pattern
is a Fourier
transform, but we don't
have to go to infinity to watch
the Fraunhofer diffraction
pattern if we want to generate
a Fourier transform optically.
We can also do it
by using a lens.
So this is what I will do today.
For the rest of the
lecture, I will show you
how a lens can produce a
spatial Fourier transform,
and what can we do with it.
So, very briefly, to remind
you, from geometrical optics,
this is--
we did this some time ago,
maybe about a month ago.
So, to remind you,
a lens is a device
that looks like a, well, at
least one curved glass surface,
typically more than one.
And it is a device
that we can use
to focus or collimate light.
So, for example, if you
illuminate a lens with a plane
wave, then the lens will
focus that plane wave
at one focal distance
to the right.
On the other hand, if
you place a point source
at one focal
distance to the left,
the lens will collimate
it, will produce
a plane wave,
which we also refer
to as an image at infinity.
And, of course, what
I am discussing here
is for the case of a
positive spherical lens.
There's other
lenses that we saw,
negative lenses that would do
something slightly different.
But I don't want to do a
full review of lenses here,
just to remind you what is
relevant to our discussion
here.
And, of course, the other
thing that lenses do
is they can produce images
as finite conjugates.
If you place an object
at some distance s sub o,
then the lens will form
an image at a distance
s sub i, which is related
to s sub o by the lens law.
So we did the stuff to that
when we did geometrical optics,
so I don't want to produce
recurrent nightmares to you
by repeating it here.
So what I will do now is
I will describe the lens
in the context of wave optics.
So, of course, in the
context of wave optics,
we have to describe the lens
as some kind of a transparency,
as some kind of a
phase function that is
applied to the optical field.
So I don't want to go into
the details of this one.
Is there a question, or--
someone has a
microphone on, so I can
hear you shifting on your seat.
Anyway, it doesn't
matter, though.
If you have a question,
please interrupt me.
Of course, this applies always.
So what is this now?
So we will do a very
crude approximation here.
We will actually neglect
the thickness of the lens.
We did this again when we
did geometrical optics.
And that is, of course, because
it is not, strictly speaking,
correct, but the results
that we get are pretty good,
and it makes our
mathematics pretty simple.
So the combination of the
two is a good justification
to make an approximation.
If you have one of
the two reasons,
it is not good to
make an approximation.
For example, if it
makes your math simple
but the answer is wrong, then
you don't do the approximation.
If you get the correct answer
but the math is not simplified,
again we don't make
the approximation.
You might as well go with
the accurate calculation.
But, in this case,
we get two bonuses.
And if we have both bonuses,
then we do the approximation.
So what is happening here,
if you take a field--
imagine like Huygens
wavelets impinging
on the lens from the left.
The wavelet that
impinges in the center
will actually see the
thickest part of the lens,
so it will sustain the
longer phase delay because it
propagates through glass.
If you take a Huygens wavelet
that actually impinges away
from the axis, it will see a
thinner portion of the lens.
Therefore, it will
have less phase delay
because it propagates a
shorter distance in glass.
It will still propagate
some distance in air
on the left and the
right of the lens.
So if you compute that
now, the difference is,
of course, it is given by
the spherical calculation.
I don't want to go through this.
You can go back and
do it yourselves.
It's a very simple
geometrical calculation,
with the addition of the
paraxial approximation.
So even if you glance at
this here, you see that--
actually, this I
copied from Goodman,
so the equations are
verbatim from Goodman's book.
It's a scan, actually.
I'm sorry.
It is not a scan.
It is a scan from my own
notes from last year.
But, anyway, it is verbatim
copied from Goodman.
And you can see that I replaced
the square root with a Taylor
expansion.
So it is a paraxial
approximation.
And the result
that you get, which
is what I really
wanted to do, is
something that looks like this.
OK.
This is what we get.
So we'll get the complex
amplitude transmittance
of the lens if you
express it in wave optics.
It is actually a
quadratic phase delay.
That's if.
And in this quadratic
phase delay,
a magical distance happens.
A magical distance
appears, which we recognize
to be the focal length.
This, if we recall from
geometrical optics,
we used to call this
the lensmaker's formula.
So, basically, we
recover the expression
for the focal length of the
lens, but now we have a wave--
I don't want to
say wave function.
That sounds like
quantum mechanics.
But now we have actually--
we have a complex amplitude
transmittance.
That's what we have
associated with that one.
So now let's see why this is the
same result as we had before.
So the trick here is that
we replace the lens--
when we have a
situation like this one,
we replace the lens
with its amplitude--
complex amplitude transmittance.
So forget about the curvature.
Forget about the glass
and everything else.
We just replace it with
a thin transparency.
And then we illuminate
it with something.
Let's start by choosing this
something to be a plane wave.
So here's the wave vector
of this plane wave.
And because it is propagating at
an angle, we write it as g sub
in.
Actually, we write
it g sub t sub minus,
because it is the
field immediately
to the left of the
transparency, of x comma y.
It is a plane wave.
Let's call this angle theta--
what did they call it?
Theta 0.
So since it is a plane wave,
the proper expression for it
is e to i 2 pi sine theta 0 up
on lambda x plus cosine theta
0 up on lambda z.
And I'm going to
do two things here.
First of all, I'm going to place
the transparency at z equal 0.
So that knocks out this
factor, because equal 0.
And then I'm going to make
the paraxial approximation,
so that knocks out the sine.
So, basically,
the field incident
upon the transparency,
upon the lens, that this,
is simply e to the i 2 pi
theta 0 x up on lambda.
So what I would
like to do now is
to compute the field after the
transparency, g sub t plus.
So the rule that we described
when we did thin transparencies
is that we multiply.
I'm sorry.
I'm using a slightly different
notation on the whiteboard
than in the notes.
You don't have a
minus and a plus,
but it's basically
the same thing.
So g sub t plus multiplied
by the transparency itself.
So the plus stands for after,
the minus stands for before,
and the nothing stands for
the transparency itself.
Oh, and another thing that I
did in the notes is I defined--
I defined this quantity u0
equals theta 0 up on lambda.
And this now we recognize
as a spatial frequency
because it has units
of inverse meters.
So what do we get now?
What do we do is a
little bit of algebra,
but it actually results
in an physically
intuitive, physically
meaningful result.
So that justifies the
algebra, I suppose.
So let me write it out.
Let me write out this
product over here.
OK, that's it.
So now I have to
do something that--
let me leave it
here so you can see.
We have to do something that
you may remember from horror,
from your high school
or elementary school.
I don't know where you
learned these things.
It's called to
complete the square.
What is the square that
I want to complete?
If you look at
the exponents, you
have an expression
that looks like this.
I'll knock out the minus sign.
x square over lambda
f minus 2 u0 x.
Can you see that?
I've neglected the y's
and everything else,
and the pi's, and so on.
If I can do that, then I
can take care of the rest.
So how can I complete the sign?
Well, I tend to get
confused with this,
so let me knock out the
1 over lambda f also.
Now it looks better.
Now I can do it.
Basically, to
complete the sign, I
have to add and subtract the
square of this business here.
And now I can write it as--
OK, now I can go
back and substitute
into my original expression.
I'm done with
manipulating the exponent.
And my original
expression was this one.
So I can rewrite out now, g sub
t plus of x comma y equals--
first of all, I have
this constant term.
That is constant.
It means it does not depend
on x, the spatial variable.
So I'll just take it out.
I should not forget my pi's.
So there's a pi over here.
So-- no, I don't like
the way this came out.
I was expecting to divide,
but I had multiplied.
OK, that looks better.
So I'm doing OK here,
because what are the units?
No units.
I have a spatial
frequency squared times
distance squared, so no units.
And what I have
left is something
that looks like this now.
OK.
So the first part, I don't
have to worry too much about.
This is just a constant
factor, as I said.
But this one, now I recognize
that's a spherical wave.
It is a spherical wave because
it contains quadratic phases
in the exponent.
It is a converging spherical
wave because of the minus sign
here.
And it's not quite its
origin but its sink.
The location where the
spherical wave becomes a point
is actually shifted by
this factor over here.
This is displacement.
OK.
So, basically, this
is what I've got.
I've got a spherical
wave which converges.
Oh, and where does it converge?
Well, the distance that a
spherical wave converges
is what multiplies the
wavelength in the denominator.
So this is where it converges.
So this is basically
what you see here.
The spherical wave
after the lens
converges to a
distance u0 lambda f.
If you substitute the definition
for u0, it is theta 0 times
f away from the axis.
And the distance between
the lens and the focus
is one focal distance.
So this is not news.
We knew this from
geometrical optics.
We just rederived it using
the thin transparency.
So this, I guess,
gives us conviction
that our approach is correct,
because we rederived something
from geometrical optics.
I will not do the next one.
The next one, I'll let
you do by yourselves.
You can repeat a similar
procedure of completing squares
in order to see what
happens to a diverging
spherical wave placed
at one focal distance
to the left of the lens.
And you can convince
yourselves easily
that this becomes a
plane wave propagating
at an angle equal to the
ratio of the displacement
over the focal length.
So this is again something that
we saw in geometrical optics.
It is not new.
OK.
The real result that I
want to derive here--
and I will try to do it
carefully in the time that we
have left--
is the Fourier
transform property which
I will do for a special case.
Actually, I will not do
it for a special case.
I'm going to--
I take it back.
I will do it for the
general case of a lens--
I'm sorry-- of a
thin transparency
placed at a distance z
to the left of the lens.
Goodman does three cases.
First, he does the
case z equals 0.
Then he does the case z equals
f, and then another case.
It doesn't matter.
We'll just do it for the
general case, and we're covered.
So what-- first
of all, let me do
the derivation in one variable.
So don't write too much.
So we'll basically skip y.
All of the derivations
will be just with x.
So I have a thin
transparency g of x.
And then what I will
do is I will propagate
it distance z to the lens.
Now, on the lens, my
coordinate is x prime.
And since I'm
propagating a field--
also, I forgot to
say-- that's quite
important-- the
implicit assumption here
is that the illumination is
an on-axis plane wave coming
from the left.
So that, if you recall,
we said a couple
of times, that is simply--
its complex amplitude is 1,
because I can choose that--
a constant phase.
And there's no x
variations with this one.
So the Fresnel propagation
kernel, if I go from z--
So g is-- let me maintain
my notation consistent here.
So to the left of the
lens, L minus of x prime--
so that is the field to
the left of the lens--
is going to be given by a
Fresnel diffraction integral.
And, actually, in my derivation,
I skipped the constant.
And what is the
constant that I skipped?
It is this one.
And this constant
should be there,
but it is not doing
anything significant for us
in this case, so that's
why I skipped it.
To save writing, basically.
So from now on, we will
basically neglect this.
Even though it is there,
we will simply neglect.
Now, the field after the
lens equals the field
before the lens times
the lens itself.
And the lens itself is
something of the form
e to the minus i pi x
squared up on lambda f.
And, finally, I have this field,
and I have to propagate it.
How long?
Now I have to do
this part, which
means I have to propagate
by distance f until I
reach the back focal plane.
And that is another
Fresnel integral.
I will call it g sub f, I guess.
Again, there is a factor
here which I will neglect.
OK.
So now let's put
everything together.
I have two Fresnel
convolution integrals--
one with respect to
the input coordinates,
the lens coordinates.
And what is left inside, I will
simply substitute all the rest.
I have the input itself.
Then I have the
propagation kernel
from the input to the lens.
Then I have the lens.
And then I have the
propagation kernel
from the lens to the
back focal plane.
OK.
That's what it is.
This looks a little
scary, but part
of the purpose of this
class is to teach you
how to not be scared by
this kind of integrals.
So the way you know
this, you don't
get scared by this
sort of integral
is you manipulate
the exponents here.
And you try to--
the first thing you
do when you reach an
integral of this kind
is you try to collect terms.
So I'll write the
exponents here.
I will expand the exponents
and collect terms then.
So if I expand the exponents,
I will get x prime squared
plus x squared minus 2x
x prime over lambda z.
This came from this
term over here.
Then I have minus x
square over lambda f.
And then I have plus--
and I think I
missed a prime here.
That should have been x prime.
Yes, correct.
The lens should also
be with an x prime.
Thank you.
It is very fortunate
that you corrected me,
because if you hadn't I
would be kind of stuck here.
OK.
So the thing that
you notice first
is that some of these
exponents get knocked out.
This one kills this one.
That's very pleasant.
Now what do I have to do?
I still need to make an
integration with respect
to x prime.
So x prime appears
here and here.
And I have to make an
integration with respect to x.
Well, here is x.
Here is x.
OK.
So what-- any ideas?
Anybody want to speculate
on what I should do here?
Let me write the integral.
That's a little bit
confusing the way it is.
Let me rewrite it so you can see
what the integral looks like.
Let me do it carefully.
So I have e to the minus i
2 pi x prime up on lambda.
That's common in
the two exponents.
Inside, I have x up on z
plus x double prime up on f.
So what should I do next?
Is there any glaring sort of
integral that popped up here?
What is-- here, we
have an integral
of another exponential, right?
And they-- let me
rewrite it like this.
OK.
So the glaring integral
that I was referring
to before is this one.
That's a Fourier transform.
Whose Fourier transform?
The Fourier
transform of whomever
appears in this
location over here.
And where is the Fourier
transform computed?
Well, it is computed in this
spatial frequency, right?
It is computed in whatever
spatial frequency multiplies
the dummy variable
in the exponent.
Now, what is this
Fourier transform?
We don't know, but we have
our notes, or we have Goodman,
or we have the
tables of formulas.
So switching to Lecture 9B.
This is our Fourier
transform pairs.
I recognize this
integral, recognize
this Fourier transform.
It is the second
row from the bottom.
If you look at this expression
and the expression over here,
it is actually the
same Fourier transform.
It is the Fourier
trans-- what you
see here is the
Fourier transform
of the quadratic phase
in the exponential.
So we have the answer.
The answer is right here.
Again, I will neglect--
actually, this constant
is quite important,
but I will be neglect
it nevertheless.
So, basically, the way to get
a one-to-one correspondence is
to simply substitute
what would--
what in the table is denoted
as a square is actually
identical to 1 over
lambda z in our case.
So I can write out
now the answer.
This thing equals-- first of
all, before I do any further,
we recognize that this does
not play in the integration.
This has the output
plane coordinate,
so I will simply
take it outside.
And then I will write out the--
in one shot, I will
write out the outcome
of this Fourier transform.
So that a square that I have
in the original function,
it will go inverse
in the other one.
So we'll get, then,
e to the what?
I will get an extra minus sign.
If I have plus j here,
I have minus j here.
So this will then
become e to the minus--
we'll have all the pi's and
so on-- minus i pi lambda z.
And then I will get the square
of the spatial frequency.
So it will be 1 over lambda
square x up on z plus x double
prime up on f squared.
OK, that's it.
So now I can manipulate
it a little bit further.
And now let me write
out all these exponents
that come out of this square.
So I will get--
the first one will be x
square up on z square.
So one z will be killed.
One lambda has
already been killed.
So I will get e to
the minus i pi x
square over lambda z, right?
Then I will get this term.
That will be e to
the minus i pi--
this is tricky-- z x double
prime square over lambda
f square.
This came out of the
square of this one.
And I will also
get the cross term.
So that will be
e to the minus i.
And then we'll do it carefully.
I will get 2 pi.
And what is left here--
one z will cancel.
I will get x x double
prime up on lambda f.
And now, happily, we see that
this additional quadratic that
was very annoying over
here, this one, it got
killed by this one.
This one is not playing
in the integration either,
so I can actually
take it out of here.
And this is the result
that I was after.
You see that I actually got
another Fourier transform.
This is well recognizable as
a Fourier transform kernel.
So what I have in
this part over here,
it is actually the
Fourier transform
of the transparency calculated
at these coordinates, that is
the argument of the integral.
Now, something
funny happened here,
and this doesn't look
quite right to me.
That should be f, right?
OK.
I don't know how this became z.
Oh, yes, yes, yes.
OK, I know now, yes.
That should be f, yes.
Somewhere in my
notes I converted
this to f, but, thankfully,
not the physics.
So this should not be z.
This should be f.
OK, so now it looks right.
OK.